thank you
[Music]
we are talking about sleep all week long
here and more importantly how to get a
good night's sleep which is crucial Dr
Nicole short is an assistant professor
over at UNLV here to talk about the
psychology of sleep and I think that's
one thing that a lot of us when we think
about trying to get a good night's sleep
it's the food we eat or you know should
we wear a certain kind of pajamas or
should our pillow be a certain height
which isn't insignificant but how much
is the Mind important when we try and
get a good night's sleep yeah so I think
that all of the environmental factors
definitely play a role but for people
who have trouble sleeping a lot of times
they've already addressed a lot of those
factors and so in that case the Mind
plays a really big role and a lot of
times people feel like they can't turn
off their mind or they can't really
relax and that's when I think the
psychology comes into play so what is it
in our mind that prevents us
from from getting a good night's sleep
what is it about our our bed that
doesn't motivate slumber
question so essentially what we would
like is for our bed to be associated
with sleep and restfulness so ideally
when you're in bed all you're doing is
either sleeping or you're very sleepy
but unfortunately when we have trouble
sleeping a lot of time people are
spending a lot of time in bed that is
not sleep so you know how do you feel
when you're laying in bed trying to
sleep and you can't
frustrated yes you feel frustrated
anxious annoyed and none of those
feelings are conducive to sleep and you
know when I in my own experience and
maybe you at home as well you feel like
you know if you at least are lying in
bed you're resting but you're suggesting
that's that's not the case so what
should we do if we're in that position
and where you start to think about how
do we fall asleep yeah
I have a misconception
um
so
some people are lucky enough to be able
to just lay in bed and never have
trouble sleeping and they can just do
everything in bed but if you do have
trouble sleeping it would be recommended
that if you can't go to sleep within
about 15 to 20 minutes to actually get
out of bed do something kind of boring
for a while like maybe read a book do a
puzzle nothing too stimulating and then
go back to bed when you actually feel
sleepy don't check your phone for
example that's right the exact opposite
exactly because that's going to get you
more wired up and
when you hear people talk about they're
having a hard time sleeping
when does it reach a point where it's
not just I can't get to sleep for
whatever reason but it's it's a clinical
thing it's something that they need
treatment for yeah so when we're looking
for insomnia disorder we're looking for
it happening pretty much more than half
the night so very often and for at least
three months so if you've had trouble
sleeping about half the time for about
three months that's when you should
start thinking about seeing someone it's
it's a big issue obviously and
especially in Las Vegas we all work such
weird hours not just on the morning show
but just with the nature of our
community Dr Short just hang on for a
second we're going to talk some more
about sleep here on Good Day Las Vegas
and hopefully getting you better sleep
as well